foreign
oh my gosh it says I miss myself I don't
know where I am
I have absolutely no idea what I'm doing
I wish I could fake my death to see how
my friends would truly react I was once
convicted of first degree murder I'd
scared of the question
because I'm not it's devastating knowing
that I will never be a kid again my
little brother cried the night I left
for college that has made me cry more
than I care to admit if he watches this
I love you little bro
I feel like this person really has a
deep connection with his with his family
I wish I had that with my family I wish
I could tell them I could tell my dad
that I love him more
um
yeah I yeah